so here at the end of the show I'd like
to take a moment to thank all the
generous sponsors who made tonight's
episode possible the P dome show is
brought to you by low-set coffee tables
and dimly lit rooms think you're
invincible not anymore you don't
a quick to a.m. shin collision with this
fella will leave you bruised and fully
aware of your own mortality
thanks low-set coffee tables and dimly
lit rooms peetam show is also brought to
you by arranging a banana and two
oranges so they look like a dish it's a
classic for a reason funny to old people
funny to children thank you so much
banana and two oranges that look like a
dick we love you and tonight's show is
brought to you by sending cash in the
mail sure only your grandma has the
balls to do it it's unsafe and I'm
pretty sure it's illegal but grandma
doesn't give up